[Applause]
a rare protest in Russia but a familiar
response police crank down on thousands
of demonstrators in the Bashan region
they were rallying to support rights
activist fil alev he's been accused of
inciting ethnic hatred for comments he
made about workers from Central Asia and
the caucuses he's always Den the
accusations but inside Court he was
sentenced to four years in a penal
colony
we will appeal the sentence I don't
understand the policy carried out by the
bishan Republic head I don't understand
what's going to happen next we don't
want this a huge thank you to all those
who support
me alen of supporters say his
imprisonment was delayed revenge for his
activism in preventing the construction
of a soda plant near the kushtown
mountain which local people consider a
sacred place the protesters chanted
freedom and demanded the resignation of
the governor of
basharan at the same time social media
Outlets supportive of the Kremlin have
accused fil alov of being the leader of
a banned organization bash Court it
Advocates the separation of the Republic
of basharan from Russia and is accused
of provoking ethnic conflicts
while protests on the scale are rare
thousands have been detained in the past
two years for opposing the armed
conflict in Ukraine and while alov was
an opponent too analysts say the protest
in basharan was directed towards the
regional authorities and not the power
of President Putin Julia shavala Al
jazer Moscow